today we are here with Anne Wojcicki
co-founder and CEO of 23andme thank you
very much we always like to start with
how you came up with the idea and the
sort of the founding story of the
company so I was working on Wall Street
that doesn't sound very fun it was fun
I loved it so I grew up I grew up in
academia I always thought I'd end up
being an academic I got buried my
parents I went to a job fair right out
of college my parents made me go and I
got this job offer to go on Wall Street
and it's one thing I always tell young
people like you never really know what's
gonna come your way you know just take
every opportunity so I very randomly got
this job on Wall Street I had no idea
what it was but I kind of figured like
actually only took the interview because
they gave me free frequent flyer miles I
won the flight
I won the frequent flyer miles so you
had to fly there but you got to keep the
frequent flyer miles yeah I was just
excited I was like it's a free trip like
it will be 5,000 miles like that's
pretty awesome
so so I was on Wall Street for 10 years
and I loved it like for me it was
because it wasn't just about like
trading and making money and doing these
things but it was like I got to learn
about companies and the thing the one
thing that is amazing on Wall Street is
that you get to go like you got to go
deep on certain companies when you're
really interested in them and then
really broad knowing a whole sector so I
got to know small cap biotechs and
pharma companies and hospital systems
and insurance companies and I got to
have like a really broad landscape of
health care and you know in the
beginning I had this eternal optimism
like health care is gonna you know
totally change
there's antibodies there's all this like
new you know there's like technology
like there's all these new discoveries
coming it's gonna be so different
and then when the bubble burst in 2000 a
lot of innovation dried up and I started
to see more what healthcare really is
and and at the end of the day health
care is an amazing business that really
effectively monetizes illness and I used
to always say you know if I successfully
get you to never be diabetic no one
makes money but if you do become
diabetic there's all kinds of ways I can
make money and at the end of the day
when I think about what I care about
what's in the best interest of me like
I'd rather just never be a bit diabetic
I'd rather never be sick
and there's no one in the system today
that really thinks about how to keep me
healthy so after 10 years of investing I
felt like I really understood the system
and I also understood that you have this
all these people with the right
intentions who really care but the ships
just pointing in the wrong direction and
that no one's actually focused on
keeping people healthy and that I want
to have a company that was frankly
somewhat rebellious and was going to
inspire people to try to really be
healthier and you know and I felt like
it was you know again it had sort of
that you know a little bit of a Robin
Hood kind of mentality in the beginning
of you know we have to you can't change
the system from within yeah so we got to
do something more radical from outside
one of my favorite Charlie Munger quotes
is incentives are super power and I
always believe this and I think this is
the clear problem you just identified so
how do you think about how you how you
design a system or a company that
incentivizes but is incentive to keep
people healthy well I realize like the
main thing in health care is that you
don't actually ever have a voice like
you don't like you don't actually
because you're not the payer in health
care like you the individual you can
actually make decisions it's you know
your insurance company your doctor the
pharmacy benefit manager there's all
kinds of people in the back who actually
make decisions and I think there's all
this data now about you know you go in
for surgery and those doctors coming
into the surgery that you've never even
met so for me what was transformative
like what we did to change the
incentives is to put you in the power
seat because I feel like like you make
retail decisions that are your best
interest because like you're actually
the one paying the bill so for us like
what we decide to do that wasn't frankly
like seen as disruptive as we are
direct-to-consumer I remember when you
launch doctors were just your health
care professionals in general were
saying patients this is this is
irresponsible you know you need a
medical professional to do this like we
can't I remember one quote that really
stuck with me something like we can't
have people making their own healthcare
decisions they don't know how to
interpret that data there is all kinds
of interest like oh ho there's all kinds
of interesting things cuz people would
publish stuff on Facebook and then
doctors say like you have to write and
we'd remind people like yeah it's their
own yeah information so there's always
been
I'd say attention a little bit with the
medical system in the medical system
historically there's tests like the
pregnancy test the pregnancy test when
it came out was seen as radical like how
could women ever possibly learn at home
that they're pregnant and if you look at
the literature of you know that era like
we look at that today and we'd say it's
crazy so one of my favorite papers is
there's this GMO paper the Journal of
American Medical Association from 1969 I
think where they asked doctors would you
tell your patients that they have cancer
if they had a cancer diagnosis and over
90% of them said no so I always put that
in context of like it helps people
understand like physicians were trained
in such a way and so I don't blame the
system or the individuals it's just like
that was the culture that was thought of
like what was actually in your best
interest and I think what we do is like
as we empower consumers we are showing
that people actually can be like people
want to be in charge of their health
they want the information and they
actually want to be in control I always
like the sort of model of thinking about
the world fifty or hundred years from
now and looking back what we think was
just totally ridiculous
yeah and this sure seems like I think
health care is a type because health
care is like really as much as its
science and it's data driven it's also
not like part of what people don't
necessary defy different physicians and
get five different ways of you know
treating cancer is because there's the
practice of medicine you can get
different opinions and one of the things
that we're specifically trying to change
is exactly that is exactly to say that
we're trying to get data so that it's no
longer a question of like hey Sam like
what what's the best in your best
interest that there's actually data to
say exactly what you should be doing how
do you think the medical system or the
health care system overall will we'll
eventually get to a place where we don't
have this misalignment of incentives you
talked about and we have data and we
have people in control their own health
care like if you could wave a magic wand
and say I'm gonna fix the healthcare
system what needs to happen I think the
reality is what needs to happen is that
we're going to have
which is like you have a universal
payment system so single coverage like
the reality is like who cares about
keeping you healthy today because you
could be you could be overweight and you
can eat poorly and you can never
exercise and you won't see the
consequences of that for the next let's
say 20 years so the reality is like
who's going to benefit from that and the
reality is like it's society and it's
you personally and it's like you know
somebody who's willing to invest in you
in the long run and I think for a
single-payer health care system or like
a country they care about actually
trying to keep you healthy for as long
as possible
I think second people like we don't want
we saw that communism doesn't yeah
support the the system that we all want
people have to be willing to spend money
and they have to step up and I think the
same way you see people stepping up with
yoga and vitamins and weight-loss
studies and you know all kinds of
different alternative cares people at
the end people at some point have to
stop and say that your health is also
your responsibility and I think the more
that we can get people personalized
information about themselves the more
that they are going to be willing to
execute on taking care of themselves
speaking of that you could have started
any so many different companies in the
health care space how did you decide
this was what's this was not an obvious
choice at the time for me it was totally
obvious so for me there's a couple
things that were happening one I always
loved genetics was my first investment
in 1996 and so in some ways it was my
first and it was my last so the genetic
revolution was happening like right in
when I started investing there was the
race of like you know getting the the
cost of the genome down it was super
exciting and I started looking at those
investments again and realizing that
you're gonna be able to buy essentially
a scan of your entire genome pretty
inexpensively and so that was the first
nugget of like okay well you can
actually start to get huge amounts of
genetic information and ii was seeing
this world of you know social networking
that social networking was happening and
you don't actually need
the old guard to get things to happen I
could crowdsource so gave me this idea
that wow if I just empowered everyone
with their genetic information and I
crowd-sourced all this information like
if I have the world's health information
what could I do and people are like well
you could you know Kuril you could say
well you can you know a lot so the idea
really was what we should do that we
should like instead of relying on
Stanford or Harvard or Pfizer to go and
solve a disease or like how to be
healthy we the people we can do it so in
some ways I like having grown up in this
Google environment and knowing you know
the social networking world that was
coming up it was piecing those things
together that was like combine the
technology and in science with the
platform that is really emerging I've
noticed that many of the most
transformative companies come because
the founder sees some like an
intersection of two pretty different but
really important trends a few years
before everybody else does and this is
clearly one of those like the fact that
crowdsourcing works is still amazing to
me just totally what's also I think when
I found her really want something
personally like for me to really want
this person oh yeah to me it was like
like the whole beauty for me of genes of
genetics is like you've
gene-by-environment
and I'll always love like people
debating but is it your genes or is in
your environment I'm like no the whole
beauty of it is that it's both so like
you might be genetically high risk for
diabetes but like there's your
environment so what can I do so very few
you know genetic elements are a hundred
percent deterministic meaning a hundred
percent likelihood that you're going to
get it so that means there's an
environmental component we can
potentially do something so let's go
figure out what you can do and then tell
people what's the reaction when you
first announced that you are going to do
this like what was it like inside the
building I think there was you know it's
always like startups are so fun because
you get a bunch of people who really
care really passionate and I think
people were excited and people knew that
there would be controversy and in some
ways I think we attract we attract
people who have all experienced the
healthcare system in their own way and
realize it has its limitations and so
there's people who are excited about 20
through me because of the mission and
they're looking to contribute
in some way to helping change the system
so there was enthusiasm and we had like
videos I like we were you know we were
also um we were super excited like to
launch and we thought there was gonna be
like this big coming like everyone and
we had tons like we had spit parties
where the cover of this like I know we
had to cover the Style section
we had the spit party in the building
but I have to say like we sold a lot the
first day and then it was slow that
happens and we were probably selling 22
you know 15 to 25 kids a day which is
not a lot how do you well I guess two
questions one how did you eventually fix
that and how did you how do you as a
leader keep momentum in the building
when you know you have this great lunch
everyone the first day is always awesome
and then you have what we call the
trough of sorrow yeah people get pretty
motivated I tried so that's actually a
good that there's always a trough of
sorrow and I think it's important to not
let people be totally you know to not
like not be wait hoping for immediate
success and then to be overly distracted
by the trough of sorrow and I think that
that actually happens not just in
launches but every time you come up with
a product you have no idea how how well
it's gonna go like I remember when my
sister first launched launched adsense
and she's like I don't know you know
we'll see how it goes like it's kind of
you know it's an experiment we have no
idea and and then clearly it went on but
part is it because you like you work
hard at it and I feel like for us and
that trough of sorry like we we
recognize like more we folk we focus on
the long term like what do we need to do
to get to this point and I think as a
leader for me one of the most important
things is not to wallow on today but to
wallow on like okay in two years this is
what its gonna look like and these are
the steps I need to do to get there
people love a vision and people love a
plan you just need to outline like this
is where we're going so when we saw that
sales were slow
we're like people don't understand
genetics but some basic market research
could have told us that that like people
don't know why they want their genetics
and then it was like okay great
now we actually need to like educate the
population about why like why would you
want your genetic information and how
did you
that so I started changing my talks like
I get I would speak a ton in the early
days like I like you gave me a
conference invite and I took it any
exactly like any any talk because part
of it is it like it's constant feedback
so again for the people who want to be
entrepreneurs like you just like you're
constantly learning constantly getting
the feedback so I would change my talks
I never gave the same talk twice like
when I look at my inventory of all my
talks it's like there's like 500 of them
because each one was slightly different
so I remember specifically getting the
feedback people question what is there a
value proposition and what you're doing
and I was like great I can answer that
question over fifty percent of my
customers get a medically meaningful
result and then I start like I started
shifting the conversation so part of it
was like getting like real-time feedback
and part of it was helping us like
define what is it that we have to do to
show the value and it was clear people
need to understand genetics they didn't
understand the basics they need to know
what is the medical utility of this and
then and then also people people need to
know that they're not the only one like
that's not weird yeah oh this is like
weird I did that we need to drive social
like acceptance and you know I'm part of
also as medical acceptance so we did a
ton it's one thing I always advise
science companies is you can't speak
like I can't just tell you like oh we're
great we have great science like no one
like no one believes that so what you
need to do is you need to publish like
you put like I never even argue a
scientist I just hand over my
publications like here you go because
that's the reality
you you speak with your data so like I
can make all kinds of claims but like
here's my data to to actually support it
can you talk about the best decisions
you made in the early days I'm people
always ask about the worst what you can
talk about if you want but I'm curious
if you look back things like that where
you learn like I need to interact with a
scientific community in this way are
there a few decisions you made that
looking back had been critical to
success I think my - the first two hires
the two founding scientists or were just
like Brian and Sergey were amazing and
so in some ways like hiring the right
for me like it was such a critical part
of the company it was a scientific
integrity of what we were gonna do and
it set a bar
the talent that we are going to hire
going forward so I think in some ways
like having the right people we noticed
that it is almost impossible to search
you can make a lot of mistakes as a
company but if you screw up the first
yes five seven hires yes it's almost so
there's a good number of like when I
look at the first 15 people there's a
good there's like a number of them are
still here and you know the others who
have left we're still very close to how
did you find this first two scientists
we found them through a friend of a
friend of a friend who and they had a
similar idea and so it was a good it
worked as a partnership but it's it's
hard I mean I would say hiring is one of
the hardest things and I think one of
the things that we've tried really hard
here in the company is we there's a lot
of smart people who have humility and
there's a lot of smart people who like
want to tell you how smart they are and
we have opted for the humility and I
think it's really important to have
people who are constantly open to
feedback and constantly open to you know
constructive criticism and learning
about other areas and I think that's
actually one of the things that did make
us successful or you know make allow us
to grow and attract other people because
it's a group of people who are really
eager to learn from others and to keep
learning I've noticed in my own looking
back on my own career that the big
hiring mistakes that I've made are
people who are really smart but just
awful to work because they won't tell
you how smart they are and and and and
the framework that I finally figured out
is it's you have to look at the net the
net output that a person has on the
organization as a whole crime even if
they do a lot themselves if they make
everybody else miserable I think it's
one of the things hiring is always
really hard and I think especially in
leadership roles if you have the wrong
person
I think I just recently watched when the
old documentaries about Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates and Jobs talking about you
know how disastrous it was when Scully
came like I kind of forgotten about some
of these stories and I realize was like
yeah if you hire the wrong senior
leadership and you don't can see very
quickly you can thank you you can it can
sink you yeah
what's it like being in a regulated
industry I think one thing that a lot of
people say when they think about they
have they want to do this really
ambitious startup like genetic testing
but they are afraid because it's
regulated so I think regulation in some
ways there's like so there's pros and
cons in some ways like when you're
regulated it means that there's rules
like there's like there's like
guidelines and you can figure out
exactly what that means so in some ways
like there's more of a path about
actually how you have to execute it
definitely also means that it's more
expensive like there are there's rules
and you don't always agree with all
those rules and when we went from an
unregulated company to a regulated
company there was definitely a pretty
major transition for us because we were
used to
you know you hire smart people what are
smart people like to do they like to
question and they like to argue and so
we would question all the time like ah
well why would you need like why do you
need that test or why do you need this
study why do you need that number of
samples and so we would question all the
time and one of the things I think in a
regulated environment again like it's
like the DMV there's rules like you just
and you follow like there's a level of
obedience so I'd like to encourage
people it's not it's not so overwhelming
to be regulated that said it requires a
lot of communication and in some ways it
requires a communication style
that's not prevalent in Silicon Valley
right yes that is hard I think that
there's a lot people people there is an
impedance mismatch there there is and I
think you know we always said like we we
thought we were Commun like I look at
some of my old communication and I'm
like oh wow that's embarrassing now my
the way we thought we were approved you
know communicating appropriately and how
it really wasn't so there's a style like
there's a style and there's a form and
there's like ways you know there's
actually like there's a path and there's
a rule it's not terribly clear you know
I think the regulatory world can do a
better job of helping outline and one
thing I do appreciate from now having
been regulated for a number of years is
that there is a bigger picture that they
see so people who work at the FDA or
people who work in government like it's
a public servant job like they
haier they care about public safety like
at the FDA like they care about public
safety there are so many companies like
we can all see them there are so many
companies trying to dupe the consumer
yes and their job like they are there to
keep us safe so I have a lot of respect
for what they do and the onus is on us
as like this startup and the new company
all these people wanting to do things in
a new way the onus is on us a little bit
to explain how we're doing it how that
works and the way they speak just like I
mentioned about scientists is they speak
in data like you can't just say like oh
no no like trust me like I'm the good
guy
right um you have to show with data and
you have to show with data in lots of
ways
so in that capacity I don't really mind
because it's like they do know they know
a bigger picture story you know some of
the people we worked with they're you
know have been there for you know 20
years and we're amazing and they have a
depth of breadth of knowledge that I'm
never gonna have and so learning there's
input to genuinely take as you look back
you know from the day you sign that your
vision on the day you sign the
incorporation paperwork - now how much
is this all played out like you thought
it would oh you was remarkable I like it
so I actually have this picture of the
day we signed and I always look at it
and I'm like one like I really dressed
in a very different way than I do today
but to our series a documents and our
okay ours from 2007 are remarkably
similar to what they are today
that's always so I think we're unusual
so like when like one of our investors
like we he has said he's like what's
amazing he's like I look back on
everything like he's like you're a
broken record in some ways that's why
it's also so easy to do speaking
engagements like because I've said the
same thing now for a decade we like
we're v we have a mission we have a
drive like I know where we're going
and it's it's been we've been able
continuously executing on it the best
companies are remarkably steadfast and
then I think it's hard to do because
entrepreneurs sort of by definition like
to start doing new things right so I
think when the hardest things for
entreprenuer that like the
you know the Arif I forgot we called it
there of Sorrows they call the trough of
sorrow I think it's important to to
stick with it like one of the things I
think like the most important things I
think I've learned at this like doing
this now is the importance of
persistence like you have to stick with
it and when you stick with it you really
see a benefit and there's things that I
see now they've done it for over a
decade and I tried like one of our
missions is to tell people anyone can be
a scientist anyone any age level it's
part of the whole reason we're directing
we're like I believe anyone you could be
eighth grade level like and you have the
the ability I love it now when kids come
to me and they're like oh I saw you
speak and because of you like I really I
was like yeah like even though I like I
you know my parents don't know anything
and I didn't really have that degree
like I'm now in a ph.d program MIT like
I get amazing stories and you never in
some ways it takes a long time to see
the consequences of your actions so it's
one of the things I emphasize to people
like if you really care about something
like if you're really passionate it
takes a decade to really see the impact
yeah I mean it's like compound growth
it's always misunderstood it always
takes longer and then the magnitude in
the left the final that out years is
always bigger than I think and I think
what happens is that people can't be
like here the whatsapp story they hear
other stories and and I say it like you
the real story is like the companies
that continue to persist even if there's
challenging and everyone usually like
the whatsapp source are the rare but
like you can be super consistent and
that's one thing like when I see the
press about us now it's overwhelming
like we just persisted yeah that's it we
don't know tonight's success
yeah ten years of persistence yes the
overnight success is that ten years of
persistence
um so you've done all these remarkable
things as a company and the one that I
think is most remarkable or sort of the
most important of the future of the
world is that I think in the last 11
years genetic testing because of you has
gone from something that people are
afraid of to something that is now
accepted is a really important part of
putting people in charge of their lives
in their health but I'd love to hear
what the next 11 years look like and you
know if we had this conversation in 2029
while we would be talking about new
accomplishments then so I said like my
my original mission like if you think
back to my Wall Street days was like I
think the system is broken like how am I
gonna be healthy so success for me is
like I would like to be healthy 200 so I
now know I have my genetic information I
can learn about things and I have set up
this research machine where I can
collect data from all my customers we
can make discoveries we give those
discoveries back to our customers I have
this amazing machine for discovery now I
want to execute on the vision of like I
would like to be healthy at 100 so like
success for me is how do I now I just
empowered you have five million people
empowered to learn about themselves and
they keep coming back we collectively as
a 5 million you know person community
and growing is that the biggest genetic
data set in the world by far yeah that's
awesome with health information yeah
yeah but like to me that's where like
there's a power in what we can do now to
make discoveries about prevention so we
have the drug discovery arm to me I look
at it as like we have two aspects I hear
like you're healthy today you want to
keep staying healthy you have a
condition that like you just have this
like so we want to have drug discovery
for that now we like to keep you healthy
and I think about who like what are the
partnerships I can do what's like what's
the community I can form to actually
help you make behavior changes so one
thing I see all the time when I meet
people like again all economic levels
all socio-economic groups people want to
be healthier they don't necessarily know
how and I see this like you know people
don't necessary know like oh or the
Doritos really bad soda really bad like
it's remarkable how much like there's a
disconnect between like you hear things
but you don't really know what are the
ways that we're gonna be able to help
have you healthy discovered anything
that is I mean obviously the whole point
of this is it's personalized but any
generally accept any any general trends
that you've discovered that apply to a
lot of people they might not already be
aware of like I think most people know
they probably shouldn't drink so much
soda know but there's probably people
like some people who could absorb more
sugar than others I think those are the
types of things like we're all pretty
different like the beauty of humanity
is that you're meant to survive like you
just look at you can look at it from the
perception of viruses like you have the
1918 flu lots of people died some people
survived some people are immune the same
thing with you know foods like some
people just can eat a lot of sugar some
people can't and that's why I like we
are still around on the planet today so
I think the main thing that I would say
take away is that there's a there's a
lot of variability 100% like you
shouldn't smoke you should exercise more
you should eat better but there is like
there's some people couldn't smoke and
never get cancer there's some people who
eat a lot and they never get overweight
like some people don't exercise doesn't
really matter how far away are we from
someone being able to spit in a tube and
you tell them like here's what you need
to do to have a good shot at that means
100 so that's one of the things that's
most exciting is like what we can do by
having a community of people who are all
engaged we're starting to do what we
call these intervention studies so we
did our first one on weight loss so we
had 70,000 people doing you know a six
arm weight loss study so that's the
first time we're doing it in that kind
of scale specifically to see based on
your DNA are there differences in weight
loss I'm also I'm personally obviously
motivated in the parkinson's space of
people who are genetically high-risk are
there behaviors that can lower your risk
and how much then can you lower your
risk so we're starting to do those types
of studies specifically because like
that's what our customers want like our
customers specifically want to know
exactly what you just have lately tell
me what to do yeah so like my like when
you say again success for me is like at
the end of this decade I will tell you
what to do at the end of like by 2020
why I look at it was like well no I look
yeah and of yeah the next ten years of
the company so I'm already 10 and 12
years in so they give me another eight
years that's pretty exciting I'm on it
I'm honest am I will follow the
instructions to the letter thank you
very much for taking the time
you're welcome anytime it's really fun
super fun